[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 83 of
the weekly Google apart from podcast I
am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mendel
hey Mark how are you doing I'm doing
very very very well how are you doing
France asked I'm pretty good it's been a
long week but you know pretty good very
excited about a very cool episode about
public datasets yeah it's super cool
where we talk about how we host all
these really large datasets for all
these people to play with and do fun
things with yeah I've used some of them
before my favorite one is we have a lot
of code from github you can do cool
things with it but it's not the only one
so we're gonna be talking about a bunch
of different ones that you can just go
and use and have fun with them and after
that we have a question of the week that
is actually a question of the week whose
answer comes from someone we interviewed
in the future so at some point we'll
have him on the podcast but for now we
have something that he proposes as a way
to have a better understanding of your
billing specifically what goes where so
if you've seen the billing dashboard is
not as detailed as it could be
so how can you see more and with pretty
graphs and colors and stuff
beautiful graphs yeah so we'll cover
that at the end it's gonna be a pretty
cool thing it actually looks really
awesome but before that we have as
always our cool things of the week
Australia yay Sydney what Ian why I
wrote Sydney didn't even answer back
from the Olympics like he is like way
back that's sharing how old I am
it's like a like an internal joke
between Australian people know when when
Sydney got announces the Olympics I
think it was called Sydney that was like
I had an accent and it's just it's a
very stupid joke I think it's only
Australian scared but maybe there's some
Australian listening to the podcast
maybe they're laughing now maybe anyway
the important thing is is that now we
have a region in Sydney which is a
pretty big deal considering how far away
from the rest of the world that
Australia actually is so latency really
makes a difference so we definitely now
have a new region in Sydney that you can
take advantage of right now we've got a
good chunk of our products available
there and they're not all there yet but
we're working on some of the pieces that
are missing most
if you use container engine which I'm a
huge fan of as well as my other stuff
that that's all sitting there and
waiting for you to go so I'm I'm hugely
excited I mean I would also be hugely
excited because right now like if you
were in places like Indonesia before you
didn't really have that much covered now
you have Singapore on one side and
Sydney and the other and then Taiwan
little bit higher up so now you start to
be really really really well covered
it's pretty amazing yeah no super super
excited by that and just you know we
keep growing and growing and growing
which I'm super happy about one more
excuse to go to Australia we have then
two different stories that are really
cool they're successful otherwise they
wouldn't have me a successful migration
stories to Google+ platform so one of
them is how bug defender migrated to
Google Club from from Amazon Web
Services it's really cool I really like
the graphics I don't know if they have
like someone working on them and
specifically or what but they look
really really cute and then on the other
side we have another story where we have
a different company this time migrating
from um pram to Google cloud platform
and the name of the company is I think
males as well because I think it's
French you might be French oh good I
could go with Mueller's meows ah ja
means better agents in French they're
gonna okay cool I like to hear you
saying no I just ruined it and I'm not
gonna do it again so yeah it's a
different company but a different
migration story from a different place
but again successful and I think that
for many of our listeners will be a
definitely interesting story to read
yeah now love it I love both of them
definitely and they both come from
different perspectives and the one from
I'm not gonna pronounce it the one the
real estate company that starts with M
because I'm gonna ruin that totally they
have great pictures to show how their
architecture works and what they changed
what they didn't change going across
from prem to cloud yeah they're both
really good articles where were three
yeah it is really cool because he got to
the detail on how like okay so how do we
do it to have your cell structure s code
and like come on click deployments and
stuff like that so like we're gonna use
Jenkins that were gonna be using ansible
like it gets in a lot of detail so it is
definitely worth having a look
especially if you're considering
migrating to cloud platform there's
definitely lessons to learn all right
cool so why don't we go get stuck into
our public datasets wait the more I can
will sounds good let's 11 a huge thank
you to the two gentlemen joining us
today we are joined by Mike Hamburg
partner operations manager at G tech
feeds as well as will current program
manager at Google cloud thank you so
much for joining us today how are you
both doing Mike how's it going today
it's going great glad to be here
wonderful wonderful and we'll how you
doing coffee's coming along good glad to
be here hey excellent it is a little
earlier than we usually get up but thank
you so much for for joining us we are
here today to talk to you about public
datasets on Google cloud platform but
before we do that why don't we just have
a quick chat about who you are and what
do you do at Google will why don't you
go first yeah I'm a program manager with
Google cloud up here in the Seattle
office and I'm focused on data and
analytics partners and I'm very
passionate about improving access to the
world's datasets one of the programs I
manage is the cloud public data sets
program cool and you Mike I'm a partner
operations manager here in the
Pittsburgh office of Google and I work
on taking data feeds and moving them
around so in this case we're moving them
to cloud predict I'm in the bubble base
that's program and doing all the
transformations that happen along with
that cool so we'll you mentioned that
you manage the public data sets programs
what what is it exactly yeah so the
public data sets program launched just
over a year ago our big next conference
in 2016 and what it is is a program
where Google Cloud hosts open data sets
in bigquery and also Google Cloud
Storage and we do a significant amount
of ETL on the data sets we're not just
marrying them on Google cloud were
improving accessibility so for example
some of the data sets that we have
ingested from data gov Mike stone Mike's
teams have some ETL on those to get
those into bigquery and what that does
for users is it allows them to be a
server less access
to query those datasets via the UI or
command line cool but what is UTL Mike
you want to jump in and cover that since
that's your port yeah that's a extract
transform and load so basically getting
the data from the source do whatever we
need to do to it make it pretty
sometimes this optimize it or do you
normalize it or or whatever needs to
happen and then loading it in this case
into bigquery
cool so at the end we end up with a data
set that is ready to be used by anyone
and that is available either on bigquery
on Google Cloud Storage is that right
yes awesome so can you give us a few
examples of what data sets we have
available either on GCS or bigquery or
wherever yeah so well we've got a
growing number of them some of the most
popular ones are github the stack
overflow dataset hacker news and then
one that we have a good relationship
with Noah and have been ingesting more
and more of their weather related
datasets yeah there's actually out of
those data sets I've worked with two of
them Noah I gave a talk that was my
first talk ago Google IO oh yeah long
time ago yeah on how to visualize all
the ships in the world using bigquery
and Google Maps it is it is a really
cool dataset it's amazing so that is now
open for everyone to use
but that's correct yeah we have several
NOAA data sets we have a global
historical daily and monthly and then we
also have Mike just completed onboarding
of I codes what are codes that's all the
oceans information back to 1662 so ships
buoys wind temperatures water temps
where the ships were that's pretty
comprehensive the answer a really
interesting question with that data set
- what was that so we took a look at
where the Titanic sank and ours
surrounding it and did a visualization
on where other ships were so both
shipping lanes kind of in the hours
before and hours after the Titanic sank
it's really neat because you can take
this historical data and plot very
visually what's going on at that time
awesome
we're talking about datasets they're
about in bigquery
and it sounds like there's a there's a
bunch of them that are super cool and
really easy to use but we've sort of
touched on it very briefly in the in the
short time we've been talking about data
sets we've got in Google Cloud storage
what are those data sets yes so the main
data sets that we have in Google Cloud
storage we've got about a one and a half
petabytes of satellite data from both
NASA and ESA the European Space Agency
and these are these are images that are
updated on a weekly basis as more
satellite images come in and then we
also just completed onboarding of over
400,000 open art images from the
Metropolitan Museum these images are
interesting because they also include
annotations of that art so for example
like what era that came from who the
artist was what the what the date was
and then we can run those through like a
vision API and output those annotations
into bigquery so that between Google
Cloud storage and bigquery you can do a
lot of interesting analysis on that cool
so there's there's a lot of cool
datasets and I'm kind of getting excited
above them and I want to use them what
are what are the conditions can I use
them for whatever I want if their
licenses are they what are the
conditions here so the main criteria for
the program is that the data be open for
public use some of the datasets carry an
additional requirement that they cannot
be used for commercial use but that is
explicit on the license associated with
the data set when you access it but for
the most part they're they're free for
use for public commercial whatever you
want to use them for nice so now I'm
wondering since you were talking about
the fact that you do ETL the extract
transform and load process to transform
that data like the raw data into a
actual data set what are the kind of
things that you that you do to that what
are the most important things that
someone might be interested in doing on
their own data before they love it to be
query yeah there's a lot of pieces to
that that I think we've learned along
the way
one of the most important things
something that we always talk about a
Google is eating your own dog food and
essentially what I mean by that is
trying out the data for yourself make
sure it works for the end users before
releasing it so
we'll do is we'll go in and throw up a
visual you know plot something in data
studio or run a query and get a result
and make sure that the values in the
table are going to work for you know the
analysts the researchers the scientists
the companies that are going to use this
data a very common thing that we do is
to denormalize the data and maybe take a
piece of information that you would
always want with that table for example
we have international census information
and in the international census
information just has codes for each of
the countries and so the codes aren't
really that useful and every single time
you use the table you kind of need to
look up like what it's code 34 mean and
so you'd want to know which country that
is so we we might join that data in
ahead of time when we load the table and
put it in there
there's a lot of standardization that
also goes into the data we try to take a
smart look at what are some things that
would be helpful for developers or for
anyone that might be using in the future
so we would take fields that maybe maybe
the data set has three three different
fields for a day a month an hour and we
can take those and we'll leave them
there but we'll add a new field that's a
timestamp so that when somebody goes to
plot this data they don't have to like
concatenate all these fields and figure
out you know transform hours and the
military time or you know regular time
and so we do a lot of analysis of data
ahead of time to prep it out of
curiosity how like I don't reason we're
dirty but how like messed up did you
find the data tends to be is it kind of
all over the place you find it's
generally inconsistent or consistent
like it depends on the source we get
some very good data from NOAA and other
partners they'd spend a lot of time in
quality control with their data other
sources not so much I would say hmm but
you know the trick is with the
government especially in the u.s. here
you know they have this mandate to you
know open up the data so they get the
data out there but often it's not in
usable format it's you know a weird it's
in a weird file encoding or it's you
know it's some arcane set up that they
have on their side maybe with their
terminology it doesn't make sense for
the majority of users so we end up kind
of bringing that in trying to parse it
and figure out what's in there what's
useful for people and we do a lot of
kind of like
joining up tables and bringing stuff
together cool so now I'm wondering like
you're saying that you at that that raw
data before you input it into bigquery
and I'm imagining that that could be
kind of a big thing right like there's a
lot of data you need to process it parse
it back clean it whatever how do you
actually do this like I imagine I would
use know like MapReduce or maybe
dataflow something like that can you
talk a little bit about this yeah we
have an internal tool that we use to
actually pipe the data through but we
definitely use the techniques like you
mentioned often doing MapReduce to
consolidate rows or expand rows we might
go from many columns to many rows if
that makes sense or vice versa and we
have a connector that picks up data via
FTP or HTTP or something whatever
protocol is used to post the data and
then we we have a loader for bigquery
and we do use the bigquery API to look
at it in I just assumed it was a big
Drive spreadsheet you know often this is
100 million rows data you know so it's
massive data sets that go through and
especially one of the key things that we
do that's different than a lot of other
places you might find this data is we
have a live connection so if that data
updates you know in 30 minutes we were
piping another iteration of that through
which means that people just need to go
to bigquery they'll have the most fresh
data that's available so I'm actually
curious like you say live what is live
mean obviously in the big data space
like seconds is nice but like we talking
hours days like what's what's that live
feeds that are like obviously it depends
again yeah it depends on the source and
how often they update I would say it
tends Ameen hourly or you know maybe
every five to thirty minutes but when
they're really big data sets even
someone like no they're not posting
these that often because they're so huge
for storage so the next question I guess
is you were mentioning that Noah for
instance they're like they're very good
partner and that they give really good
data but we also have a lot of other
different partners that provide us with
data why do they
why would they do this thing for free
well a lot of cases like as Mike
mentioned before like especially with
government data is there's a there's an
mandate to make this data available but
what we're learning is like especially
through the relationship when NOAA is
not only are they encourage just more
storage costs over time you know if they
didn't add any more data over time those
costs are mounting but also they're
getting they're collecting more and more
data you know we're moving into this
Internet of Things world where there's
more monitoring devices and so their
data is growing daily exponentially so
the problem they have is they have to
distribute this data to you know they
have thousands of users that are
interested in this weather data and so
the egress charges like never mind their
own storage costs the egress charges are
getting out of control and so what they
see is valuable from different platform
partners that have these open data sets
programs like ours is that they can push
distribution - you know like five
platforms right and then point users to
those platforms so that they aren't you
know incurring egress on Noah's servers
you know every minute so we're seeing
this example as we talk to more and more
partners that have open datasets
excellent and then there are some other
cases where like a non-government agency
that has open data they're releasing
that open data with the hopes that
people will run you know like an ml use
case on it to do some interesting things
that you know they just don't have the
resources to do internally so that that
segues into my next question which is
what sort of stuff have you seen people
do with these data sets that have been
particularly interesting yeah so our own
Felipe Hoffa had kind of teed this off
is I don't know if you remember the
Silicon Valley show where they had the
tabs versus spaces debate and so Felipe
took the github data set that we had to
kind of prove this debate and he ran
several queries to show that in fact
spaces were most popular in every
language except ironically go so
that was a pretty interesting analysis
that got picked up by a lot of the
different communities yeah I saw that
analysis and every elected specially I
mean I'm a gopher I read go surprised
shocking I know but the funny thing is
that yeah there's a lot of people that
was like oh you can go you write
everyone writes tabs and then another
language everyone at bright spaces which
is fine but then some languages was like
Wells half-half that is cool is there
any other use case I'm thinking about
for instance there was this really cool
contest with Cargill the YouTube thing
or the 8 million
yeah the 8 million do you have any big
data set that people could use for
machine learning at that kind of big big
scale yeah like I mentioned before we're
releasing the Metropolitan Museum open
art images and then we're also working
with some different third parties that
provide medical image datasets so these
will be radiology images and one of the
use cases there is that the community
can run machine learning on these
radiology images to try to classify and
detect different anomalies and those
images whether they're like tumors are
different different growths
so we're trying to find all sorts of
different large data sets that are
public domain to provide to the the
community to start you know building
different classification models cool
mark did you have any other examples you
want to add yeah we've been doing a lot
of work around city data that's been a
hot topic around you know data.gov and
these cities are opening up a lot of
their information about how the city
works and things like 301 calls or fire
station response police incidents stuff
like that so you know Rado who's a
developer advocate on our our team has
been doing some interesting analysis
things like where's your car most likely
to be broken into in San Francisco or
how long does it take the fire station
to get to a fire he did a really cool
thing in New York City about which
borough is the rat capital based on
3-1-1 calls about rat complaints but
there's all kinds of interesting city
data that's out there and avail
and we're really just starting to pick
up on that bring that in to bigquery so
people can you know dream up new things
and also analyze across cities I think
that's one of the really big values of
the program is taking one dataset and
merging it with another dataset for
example some of the medical data they
merge that with the census data and so
because we have all those datasets
available it's easy to join them and
pull another information and kind of
make your dataset more compelling yeah
right rado stuff is really interesting
too as Mike mentioned because he's also
pulling in weather related data to show
how different there's different
correlations between events from the
city data interesting so seeing like how
if rain affects that in a cab traffic
yeah cab traffic bike you know bike
usage he there was just some and also
uses it just to show that you may see
correlations but that doesn't
necessarily mean there's um you know a
statistical really yeah it's like one
was I can't remember Mike wasn't
something like on snow days there was a
higher percentage of lost manhole covers
or something weird like that that's good
yeah that's some way to do is that like
whole spurious correlation yeah
data I'm also wondering if there's like
opportunity here to like do competitions
between cities because you know how
cities love to have rivalries oh yeah
that could be fun lots of fun so I'm
wondering long time ago when I used the
NOAA data said one of the things that I
ended up using at the same time was
these other data set that allowed me to
basically go from country to continent
for instance is there such a data set
like it's basically like the knowledge
graph for Google I don't know if you
know Google knowledge graph allows you
to basically ask about facts is there
such a thing that you can mix with
bigquery easily to ask that kind of
questions taxable countries around the
world yeah for instance let's say that
you have it let's say that you have a
data set and the data set is telling you
about things about countries right but
you your question is actually I don't
care about the country I care about the
continent level so now you want to ask
well given the country give me the
continent is there such a generic or
general data set that people can use
yeah we've been building these will call
utility data sets and so pretty good
example that is
might have a data with addresses their
zip codes that you want to know you know
actually plot these woods like latitude
and longitude so we've been building
these join tables essentially that are
there I don't think we have one that is
country to continent but that'd be
pretty easy to set up since there's not
very many continents but we do have all
kinds of like especially in the US all
the different geographical points like
zip codes state county all that stuff
you can pull in and then we're doing
some stuff on some future data sets that
will have kind of more comprehensive
look at the different data you can pull
together I could just read ok don't like
what data sets are you working on or
something like that like what data sets
do you think that people might get
excited about that are coming yeah I'll
start and then Mike you know this uh
we're working on like Mike mentioned
early trying to get more City themed
data sets in so like Austin London I've
also started doing some research on what
it would take to get like Tokyo and the
problem is that in order to do
interesting joint analysis between these
data sets you have to have common joint
keys and there's no really standard
schema for all this municipal data so
trying to patch it together and it's a
lot of the work that Mike's doing and
trying to make it so that it can join
together is quite a challenge but you
know I'm hoping that we see more and
more of these data sets come out of the
Meuse abilities so that we can you know
start doing different analysis across
cities and data set that I'm excited
about that we just launched and that
we're also working on is around air
quality so you know we're all wandering
around cities and in different places
and you don't really necessarily pay
attention to the quality of the air and
so we recently released 27 years worth
of EPA data that shows all the different
particulates in the atmosphere and for
you know thousands of locations around
the US and we're working on some future
stuff that will show even more more
real-time information about what's going
around going on around the world
that sounds really useful and scary so
we're gonna running out of time but is
there anything else that you like to
mention before we finish yeah so as we
mentioned me Ben
partnering with NOAA and we have lots of
really great partners in the data space
and quick success story that I can share
in the first few months of this year we
diffused about 200 times the amount of
traffic that they would have expected on
their data sets with people using
bigquery instead so this is real savings
for them because they don't have to
incur that cost of both load on their
data sets and also all those eager
charges that they that they get this is
saving taxpayer dollars and also making
their data more accessible and available
and that's a big big important goal for
the government awesome so I guess that
the last question is if someone has a
huge data set that they'd like to share
how did they get in touch yeah we'd love
to hear from the community on what other
data sets they'd like to see in the
program they can reach out to us by
emailing GCP - public - data at Google
calm cool we'll have a link to that
email in the show notes
and you'll hear hear from either Mike
Rowe myself fantastic alright well we'll
mark thank you so much for joining us I
want to Suzanna and go play with these
data sets we really appreciate you
taking the time to chat to us about the
public data sets that we have available
on Google cloud yeah thanks for having
us yeah it's great thank you thanks so
much again to both mag Hamburg and we'll
current for taking the time today to
talk to us about all of these really
really interesting data sets
there's definitely data set that I knew
about yeah and that was like oh they're
cool but I didn't know many of them so
I'm gonna be definitely using some of
those for my demos but I know that some
of the people might be able to use for
like actual useful things actually
useful things rather than just
ridiculous stuff I like pretty because
they're most they're fun excellent all
right why don't we get stuck into the
question of the week sure I think the
question of the week was basically okay
so I'm able to see how much money I'm
paying for Google cloud platform
mm-hm and I'm able to see pretty much
from a high-level point of view where
that money why the money is being built
like you're able to see that many hours
of like whatever kind of instance using
or storage or networking or stuff like
that but I actually want to have a
better view like I really wanna drill
into
more detailed data how do I do this so
this is really cool this is an article
that was written by Mike zini and Ryan
McDowell will have links to all of this
in the show notes where they combined
Google clouds billing export to bigquery
functionality we've Google Data studio
which is a really great tool for
visualizing data that's inside bigquery
and what they do is they basically put
together a variety of graphs and
filterable you is that you can use to
see really at a glance but also at a
deeper level exactly what's going on
inside your project and across projects
as well like and so you can see I'm
looking at engine spend for example or
I'm seeing comparatively different
products that I'm using across all my
projects and it gives me a lot of
insight into exactly what's going on
inside my projects and my applications
and the money that I'm spending what's
super sweet about this is that we'll
link to this as well the demo that is
available so you can go see exactly what
this dashboard looks like has a how to
copy section not super cool and it has
step-by-step things where so you don't
have to build this thing from scratch
and like import all the sequel
statements or do anything like that
it's literally sort of five six seven
steps something like that to basically
copy all this stuff across creating a
data store some bigquery copying across
the workbook and then you can take
advantage of this thing and then
customize it if you so desire that kind
of stuff and it's it's super super super
nice in my opinion actually a cool thing
is not the fact that you can copy it
copying it is cool I think the cool
thing is that it is just like framework
and you can build on top of this and
adapt it to whatever project you're
using which is pretty amazing like if
you know how to use sequel you know how
to use bigquery and now you can do
pretty amazing queries to basically
drill down into your actual data and
then present it in a super cute way
cloud data studio it allows you to
expose information in a very very visual
way meaning that even though you're
working with hard data you're able to
present it so anyone can understand
what's going on which is very very nice
new article it links to a video that was
from next this year that was done by Ian
Lewis and Vicky Iglesias explaining
basically all the details around this
but they show some stuff in there where
you can do stuff to say predict the
future like way do you think your
buildings going and what you're doing
and some fancy math to enable that to
happen - yeah I know it is really cool
as soon as you start having lots of data
and you're able to do analysis with
bigquery you were able to do not only
analysis of the past but also like get
very good predictions and not only that
what I really like is that you're able
to do even correlations there's very
advanced correlation analysis on big
query there are just like functions that
you can call you can find correlation we
could help you find causation on your
billing things so which is really really
cool it's basically if you're a data
scientist you should get very very
excited about it
excellent all right well Francis we are
running out of time but what are you up
to what are you doing what's cool and
exciting in your world so by the time
these comes out I will be already in New
York for cucum New York City where I'm
going to be presenting go tooling in
action workshop based on the video that
I published a long time ago go tooling
in action and this is going to be open
sourced so it will be my github I'm
working on it it's a lot of content but
we'll be there by Friday because that's
when I'm running and then after that and
coming back to San Francisco for a week
and then I'm gone again this time to
Denver for gopher con where I will be
also running two workshops kubernetes
and gr PCE and stuff like that all in go
what about you awesome well literally
the day this comes out that evening here
in San Francisco will be hosting play
crafting yet again they're doing their
june play test night so we rehearsing
them and it's always fun to go down and
see all the games that people are
working on and get to play them and do
all sorts of fun stuff like that and
pizza and pizza
and as well as that in july i will be
going to the new york summit that will
be on the 18th of july i will be talking
with a company called Phoenix won games
they have a new multiplayer and mobile
game called Guardian kingdoms that's out
right now
that will be talking about their
infrastructure and how they built their
stuff on GCP cool that sounds lots of
fun so have fun in New York I will I
will have fun in New York to thank you
again for being part of the podcast
actually maybe it's time to remember our
tour listeners had to get in touch with
us we've been getting more questions
which is awesome we want those questions
keep on sending them and the way to send
them is through our email hello at GCP
podcast you can also get in touch with
us via twitter at GCE podcast or on
Google+ plus GCB podcast we have a
subreddit slash are slash GC podcast we
are also in slack on the hash podcast
channel on bitly slash tcp - slack final
all of those things are actually
accessible from our web page at GCP
podcast.com perfect that sounds really
great well so again thank you and thank
you for listening wonderful and see you
all next week
you